today i'm directing every member of the
cabinet i mean this sincerely everyone
to take a hard look at their agency
spending
and make sure it follows my buy american
standard
one of the things i admire about the
president's plan is it's fully
paid for and i think that that's an
important feature of the plan
you know right now we've got to make
sure we're making smart investments for
the future
we can invest now or we can pay the
price later
i'd rather invest now we don't believe
that the cost should be on the backs of
the american people we believe that
corporations
should be able to bear the brunt for
investing in
america's workers
well some of the sound as they get ready
to launch this infrastructure
bill it's actually spending bills a
couple of them
meantime the house problem solvers
caucus which is
democrats and republicans in the house
writing a letter saying this as the
117th congress
begins to debate various infrastructure
proposals we are writing to ask
that you continue to promote a
bipartisan path forward
we believe that a bipartisan bill would
summon the highest level of support
for the large investment needed to
repair and modernize our infrastructure
for the 21st century good luck with that
it doesn't look like it's going that way
let's bring in our panel charles hurt
opinion editor for the washington times
charles lane opinion writer for the
washington post and a guy who's not
charles
bill mcgern columnist for the wall
street journal
uh all right charlie first to you the um
you know listen there's this hope for
bipartisanship but
everything you hear uh it seems like
it's lining up
uh to be a hard fast push with democrats
yeah it sounds like republicans in
washington have finally found their
voice
against uh deficit spending again which
is a very good thing
and especially in a place a time like
right now where you have people like joe
biden who think
that the response uh the answer to every
problem is to spend more money that we
don't have
and the problem with this in particular
is if we're talking about spending two
trillion dollars on
infrastructure on top of 1.9 trillion
dollars that
that they've already spent in money that
we do not have
on covet relief which is sort of a
that's a pretty loosely defined
uh definition of that of that bill the
problem with it of course
is that you know when joe biden says
he's not none of this is going to be
paid for
by people who make below 400 000 a year
that's a complete fabrication that's not
possible it's not going to happen
the way this is going to get paid for is
through
deficit spending and printing money and
when you do that
what you wind up doing is uh the people
with the least amount of spending power
who earn far below 400 000 a year are
going to be the ones that get punished
the most
when you start seeing inflation and
their ability
to purchase shrinks
bill uh bill the there is a wrinkle
tonight axios is reporting uh this that
president biden is unlikely to propose
reinstating state
and local tax deductions this is the
salt
taxes and his second tax and spending
package despite pressure from several
fellow democrats according to people
with direct knowledge of the planning
why that matters that stance could
complicate his goals of passing a
multi-trillion dollar
infrastructure proposal again from axios
tonight there's some democrats in blue
states who'd like to see those
deductions back for state and local
taxes
right right well i mean one of the
reasons maybe for the revenue that they
need that rather the federal government
get it
then it go back you know that that the
states benefit
people uh benefit back in the blue
states look when you have anything this
big
i mean one of the alarming things is not
that it's just so big
is that we have this silly idea that big
is good inherently good
and that we can just put words on it
like smart
smart decision paid for meaning we say
we're targeting this person to pay for
it
growth i mean does anyone remember
solyndra and
shovel ready and all that i mean we just
call it green we call it this
and i think we're going to get a big
waste of money and i think the reason
is joe biden's presumption here
is not to let ordinary americans spend
and invest
the way they judge and see fit but that
the government knows better
and that it's the federal government
over state local for example
i wouldn't think the federal government
would have an idea like
which roads to fix in my town we think
they're going to
make wise decisions all over the country
by
putting up as high as we can and it's
just one of the
perverse things about washington is that
the bigger it is
the more you spend the fewer questions
seem to be asked we're all judging these
things by the size like the covet bill
i'd like to know if it really helps
people that it's intended to help
i don't think this bill is going to do
anything except yield a lot of scandals
and so forth about how money was spent
you know we're going to do a piece on
that because in the past when big money
from the federal government goes to
state and local governments
tomorrow we're going to do it it takes a
long time number one
and those local officials or state
officials will say that the projects are
exponentially more expensive
not only that but the regulations that
are in place you know that's the whole
shovel ready
jobs right now are they ready uh
meantime the progressives
are calling for a lot more here's
alexandria ocasio-cortez
i think the how that 2.2 trillion 2.25
over eight years i have serious concerns
that it's not enough to realize
the very inspiring vision that biden has
advanced
and so i believe that those of us here
and
especially as progressives within the
democratic party
we know that there is so much more
opportunity here
and in order for us to realize this
inspiring vision
we need to go way higher
her way higher chuck is 10 trillion
dollars
i'm sure joe biden was delighted to see
that because
in contrast it makes him look like a
centrist and a moderate it probably
will help him sell this package and you
know look
this is a
big push by the democrats to get through
a whole bunch of priorities before the
2022 election for two reasons
one so they can run on it and two in the
likely event that they
lose the house just because of midterm
patterns and gerrymandering they'll have
these programs in place
for years to come it isn't true it's not
paid for they're
purporting to pay for it through taxes
on corporations and you know the bad
news for the republicans is
they can complain about that but that is
popular
the polls show people support higher
taxes for corporations
and they support higher spending for
infrastructure which is
why they've labeled a lot of things in
this that aren't really necessarily
infrastructure
infrastructure i would not underestimate
the ability
of president biden to get this through
that's interesting because it is all
about the numbers and there's a lot of
people that
are wavering democrats and obviously not
republicans but you mentioned the
corporate taxes uh fbn had this piece
linking to
aei studies that's obviously a
conservative think tank but also
a cbo had said that a conser one percent
increase in the corporate tax rate
correlated with
a 0.5 percent decline in real wages
and 2007 cbo determined that workers
pay more than 70 percent of the cost of
corporate taxes
now it's a tough pitch to make charlie
but if you look at the past that's
what's happened
yeah well people are not in favor of
taxing corporations if it means that
they lose their jobs and that's going to
be the problem here
and that clip you just played of
alexandria ocasio-cortez is kind of an
amazing one
because the entitlement that she
exhibits the entitlement to other
people's money that she exhibits in that
is kind of extraordinary
well we'll have a lot more to talk about
with this and add up the votes on
capitol hill when it happens when we
come back tomorrow's headlines tonight